Scoot a lot of people are looking toward
you to be the Damian Lillard replacement
the new Damian Lillard does that
pressure to you
feel like that's pressuring you
um just because people think you know I
want to beat a new name I don't I don't
even think like that there's no pressure
like I'm School Henderson so
um I've never been pressured like that
you know the only pressure that I have
is from from myself the pressure I'm
putting on myself to be the best version
of myself that day to maximize that day
and to go out there and you know kill my
opponent let's go out there and just
help my team out on the win
um
I don't think there's no pressure in me
trying to build a new name I'm not
trying to be a new game it's a new era
for a reason so I'm here to be School
Henderson